i am so nervous though i
really really really hope that i don't
get imposter first
a few minutes later is there a way to
mute myself
uh yes on discord um near the bottom
next to your name this little microphone
icon oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god i
knew it oh my gosh guys i'm so scared
what do i do
how do i get in there
[Music]
all right so aoc has found the body
[Music]
he was in uh i don't electrical i think
that's where i was
mm-hmm yep i didn't even know i recorded
myself
myself we're on the right i didn't even
know i reported that on myself
i didn't see pokey i did not meet pokey
how many people are worth
all i see listen all i'm accounting for
is hassan dude
all right
more than foreign true
i can't kill pokey she's so nice i can't
do that
sorry pokey i know
well well well ain't that a shame
no no let me let you break it down right
all right i'm running
i'm running around cams with pokey with
aoc
we chilling we're having a great time
pokey and aoc going to cams
aoc creeps up behind pokey slits her
throat
whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait who was
that
who was the third person there and myth
what what task were you doing
i was doing the alignment and engine
yeah i don't know where that is it's
with like the crosstalk how can she be
there if she doesn't even know what the
room is like
what the hell what i'm sorry
oh no i cannot carry this game by myself
oh my god this is gonna be the fastest
game ever
i can't do this oh my gosh
i have to fix the lights right
i locked myself in okay oh yeah we
definitely know it was somebody wrong
away from no toast is just closing doors
like crazy now
do we do we do it first round of the day
yeah i'm doing it i'm doing it
afterwards r.i.p
i like that i'm going to keep playing
this game all right
you need to click on aoc are you are you
really going to do this to me ethan
no i'm not voting for owlette thank you
thank you very much thank you that's my
ride or die right there that's my ride
or die right there
i got you again you guys messed it up we
got four of them you guys
got it i was trying
honestly it feels kind of like an honor
to get murdered
i was like i don't want to be impossible
but you know what i faced my fear
yeah you got two kills i mean yeah
yeah that was loki a little too good
to press that emergency button last game
did you
no that's the meta gaming you are trying
to kick me off
just for vengeance do i vote for him
she literally just wanted to kill me oh
my god toast
[Laughter]
um um
um oh no
okay whoo maybe it's ilhan
because no one's dying
someone just locked it
hmm very
[Music]
suspicious
oh no i think it was ohan
the way she was like where were you
we're about to find out if i threw him
[Music]
off
oh my god
i think she got four kills that game
holy smokes
you just press the button right i've i
figured it out
it's ill-hot energy cold oh my god it's
gonna be
amateur hour up in here okay
what are we gonna do
report oh i
i walked up on it
hassan
please don't let anyone come wait do i
hit this
my voting patterns are very suspicious
guys are we sure
i'm giving it all away was it alejandro
subjected
now i'm on this on my own i'm wracked
with guilt
why intensity what did i do i was on the
meteors
wow it pains me to do this these are
painful votes
be right oh man if this is right if
lupero
who hasn't completed their
[Music]
oh time you got off the front page you
could tell
you could tell from the very slow pace
of murders that were going on
wow you need help
no i was being indecisive and i
alex did you kill anyone no you were
doing all the work
i was so scared again thank you all so
so so much i'm so thrilled
you know watching you all in chat was so
amazing the positivity was really great
so i'm hoping i can do this again soon
um but this was a total blast thank you
all
so much have an awesome night make your
plan to vote
and let's go take back our democracy
bye
[Music]
you